the game of thrones book series is
called
a song of ice and fire there are five
books out so far with more still being
written to finish the story
there are also some side books which
describe the history and world of
westeros
and there's a prequel series called the
tales of dunk and egg
three novellas about a knight and his
squire set 90 years before
a game of thrones compared to the main
story which is
huge and complex and intense the tales
of dunk and egg
are short simple and sweet with a
lighter tone
and smaller scale but they do have
mysteries
and secrets of their own as well as
interesting interconnections with the
main series
the first story is called the hedge
knight it introduces
our heroes dunk and egg as they're
caught up in events that change the
course of history
in westeros the hedge knight was adapted
to a graphic novel with
artwork by mike s miller and mike crowl
which you'll see throughout this video
so what happens in the hedge night and
what does it mean
our hero is a young man called dunk he
wasn't born into a noble family or magic
bloodline like the starks or targaryens
he was an orphan in the slums of king's
landing
growing up in the alleyways and pot
shops of flea bottom
dunk isn't particularly smart or skilled
but he is extremely tall and strong and
he has a good heart
a sense of right and wrong when dunk was
a kid
a knight called sir alan took dunk in as
his squire
arlen wasn't a fancy noble knight he was
a hedge knight which is more like
a mercenary wandering from place to
place wherever a lord
needs their sword hedge knights have a
bad reputation
some of them become bandits or robbers
but sir arlen taught dunk the values of
a true knight
to protect the weak and innocent and to
fight for what's right
at the start of the story sir alan dies
so dunk
feels lost he spent his whole life
serving arlen so
what now dunk takes up arlen's sword
and decides to be a knight himself the
thing is
you can't just decide to be a knight you
have to be knighted
by another night in a special ceremony
and it's implied that dunk was never
knighted
he tells people that alan knighted him
but it's hinted
that that's a lie dunk always gets
awkward and evasive when people ask him
about his knighting
and he thinks to himself that he's not a
knight
but maybe being a true knight is about
more than a
ceremony the story explores what it
really means to be a hero
dunk heads for a tournament at ashford a
chance to prove himself as a knight
and along the way dunk meets a young boy
he's completely bold and he says his
name
is egg he's confident and cheeky and
asks dunk to take him to the tourney as
his squire
dunk refuses at first so egg just
follows him
until dunk accepts they've got sort of a
shrek and donkey odd couple dynamic
where they annoy each other at first but
gradually become
unlikely best friends the tournament
is full of excitement and splendor
colorful
tents and banners merchants and
entertainers famous lords and knights
warriors from all over westeros come to
joust and fight
lannisters baratheons and tyrells tarlys
freys and dondarrions
and targaryens the hedge night is set
90 years ago when the targaryens still
ruled westeros
so the king is deron targaryen and his
queen
is miriam martel daeron's son and
heir and hand of the king is prince
bailor targaryen
called breakspeare balor is a famous
knight
he's chivalrous wise widely loved and
respected
balor comes to the tournament with his
son vala
and baylor's brother prince micah comes
with his sons
daeron aerion and aegon maika has
another son named aemon but
he doesn't come because he's studying to
be a maester at the citadel
aemon grows up to become maester aemon
jon's mentor at the night's watch
90 years later dunk meets arion
and finds that he's a total [ __ ] he's
rude
cruel vain think like joffrey but with
better hair
dunk also learns that daeron and aegon
are missing
apparently they've run off somewhere
dunk
wanders the tournament and he gets a
crush on a girl called tanzel who works
a puppet show
he hires her to paint a sigil on his
shield to represent himself
as a knight he chooses an elm tree with
a shooting star
cause dunk saw a shooting star at camp
the other night
and instead of calling himself sir dunk
he invents the name
sir duncan the tall so dunk creates an
identity for himself
as a knight but what kind of knight is
he
is he cruel and vain like arion or a
chivalrous like bailor breaks beer
what does it really mean to be a hero
that night prince arion attacks the
puppet girl tanzel
cause tanzel performed a puppet show
about a dragon being slain
and arion considers himself a targaryen
dragon so he gets offended and starts
breaking
tanzel's fingers so dunk instinctively
runs in
and beats up arion to defend this damsel
in distress
it's the right thing to do but it's also
a foolish thing to do
westeros is unfair and hedge knights are
not allowed to hit
royal princes dunk could be punished
with death
so is this heroism or stupidity
in tanzel's puppet show she says all men
are fools
and all men are knights it means we all
have some desire to be a romantic hero
to save maidens and fight dragons and
that feeling is
ridiculous and foolish but it's also
part of what makes us
human arion almost has dunk killed on
the spot
but he's saved by egg it turns out that
egg is
not some random peasant he's actually
prince
aegon targaryen son of prince micah
and grandson of the king egg explains
that his father micah wanted daeron to
write in the tournament with egg as his
squire
but daeron hates riding and fighting so
instead he ran off and got drunk
and he shaved eggs head to hide his
silvery gold blonde hair
which is famously a feature of
targaryens
egg says daeron didn't need to shave
because he just has brown hair
he also mentions that their uncle baelor
also has
dark hair instead of blonde because of
his dornish mother
all this talk about targaryen hair color
might be a hint
supporting the theory that jon snow is
the son of rhaegar targaryen and lyanna
stark
the story is showing us that not all
targaryens are blonde
so jon snow could be rhaegar targaryen's
son
but still have the dark hair of his
mother lyanna
so anyway deyron went on a bender but
egg still wanted to be a squire at the
tournament and that's why he attached
himself to dunk
egg apologizes for lying about his
identity but dunk forgives him because
he also lied to get what he wanted
implying that dunk lied to become a
knight
just like egg lied to become a squire
egg points out that he and dunk
are both from king's landing even though
donk is from the slums of flea bottom
while prince aegon is from the palace on
the hill
so the story often explores dunk and
eggs different perspectives from their
different social classes
arion demands that dunk be punished so
dunk asks for a trial by combat
and arion raises the stakes demanding a
trial of seven
a trial of seven is a fight of seven men
against seven so duncan and arion each
need to find
six allies to fight alongside them this
is
pretty unfair for dunk because prince
aerion can easily get his kingsguard
knights and his father and brother to
fight with him
it's much harder for dunk to find allies
because no one knows who he is
and who would want to risk their life to
fight for a hedge night against
targaryen princes
but dunk and egg do fine to some allies
egg knows one guy and a couple more want
revenge on
arion for being such a prick and this
bloke lionel baratheon signs up purely
for the [ __ ] banter
this is the first trial of seven in a
hundred years and lionel doesn't want to
miss
out lionel is a famous knight he's
called
the laughing storm for his habit of
laughing at his opponents while he beats
[ __ ] out of them
lionel is an ancestor of king bobby b
and gendry and stannis and shireen
and we know from the history book that
years later lionel actually fights
against dunk
but that's another story dunk also
recruits young
raymond fossaway raymond has a falling
out with his cousin stefan cause stefan
betrays
dunk by promising to fight for him then
joining arion
instead cause arion promises to make him
a lord
this creates a split in house fossa way
that still remains to this day
stefan's line are the red apple fossa
ways while raymond's are the green apple
fossa ways
because raymond would rather be an
unripe green apple than a rotten wormy
red one
like stefan so on the morning of the
trial
arion has seven nights but dunk
desperately needs
one more he begs the crowd for a
volunteer
asks are there no true knights among you
because every knight swears an oath to
defend the innocent
but all these knights and higher lords
refuse him
cause the nobility like stefan fossaway
have selfish political reasons to side
with their prince
even when their prince is wrong it's
only a poor low-born man like dunk who
has no political prospects and nothing
to lose
who's willing to fight for what's right
which shows the corruption
and injustice of this feudal class
system
but just when all hope seems lost prince
balor breaks beer
joins dunk he says dunk was a true
knight
to fight against arion so maybe there is
hope
for justice the combat begins and
14 armored knights crash together
dunk gets knocked off his horse and
arion gets the upper hand dunk is not as
skilled or well trained as prince arion
but once they're down in the mud dunk
has the advantage
because donk has experience fighting
dirty on the rough streets of flea
bottom
so he's able to defeat arion and end the
trial
so for a moment it seems that this game
of thrones story has a happy ending
dunk the heroic underdog gets justice
over the shitlord prince but prince
balor
acts all weird he's confused and slurry
and when they pull off his helmet some
of his brain
falls out his head got smashed in in the
fight
so prince bailor breaks beer falls to
the ground
and dies everyone is horrified by
balor's death
he was heir to the throne loved by all
everyone thought that he would be a
great king
so at the funeral baelor's son valar
asks
why the gods would take prince balor for
the sake of
dunk the hedge knight what kind of
justice
is this dunk speaks with baylor's
brother micah
micah was always resentful living in the
shadow of his more popular
brother kind of like how stannis is
resentful of robert
but my car reveals that it was his mace
that killed baelor
it was an accident but now micah has to
live with the knowledge that
he killed his big brother so like valar
maika asks
what's the meaning of this tragedy dunk
replies that
maybe baylor dying to save dunk will
have meaning
if one day the realm needs dunk
maybe dunk has some special destiny
balor's death is actually the
fulfillment of a prophecy
because before the trial daeron comes to
dunk and apologizes for siding with
arion
daeron feels like he's a failure and a
disappointment to his father micah
and he uses drinking and sex to cope
similar to
tyrion's relationship with his father
but daeron also says that he
had a dream about dunk in the dream
there was a dragon and the dragon dies
but
dunk survives daeron hopes that the dead
dragon means that aerion will die
but as it turns out the dragon who dies
is balor
this fits the pattern of many prophecies
and dreams in the series
they come true but in an unexpected way
many targaryens have prophetic dreams
and they often lead to
destruction we know from the history
book that after the hedge knight
king daeron and prince valard die in a
plague
when king daeron's other sons die micah
becomes king
but then maika dies in battle dare on
the drunken dies of the clap and arion
drinks wildfire because he thinks it'll
transform him into a dragon
which leaves the realm in a bit of a
succession pickle
who should be the next king daeron and
aerion both had kids but no one wants
them on the throne
so they offer maester aim on the throne
but he refuses
so the next king of westeros is egg he
becomes king
aegon targaryen v and king egg
chooses dunk to lead his kingsguard so
dunk from flea bottom
rises to the highest position for a
night in westeros
king egg's rule was difficult with
rebellious lords and
rebellious children and later in life he
became convinced that the solution to
all his problems was
dragons he was obsessed with trying to
hatch some dragon eggs experimenting
with
sorcery wildfire and ancient lore
and this dream of dragons ended in
tragedy
a mysterious fire at summerhall killed
king egg
and most of his family and dunk
one of the only survivors was egg's
granddaughter raela
and it's hinted that she was saved from
the fire by dunk before he died
then while summerhall burned behind her
raela gave
birth to rhaegar targaryen the brother
of viserys and daenerys and the father
of jon snow so maybe dunk was
right there was a day when the realm
needed him
if he hadn't saved raela rhaegar and
daenerys and jon snow would have never
been born
the whole series wouldn't have happened
and all of this began
with dunk seeing the comet that inspired
his heraldry
a comet or bleeding star is part of the
prophecy of azor ahai
the hero that'll save the world rhaegar
believed that his son would be this hero
when he saw a falling star
so dunk is deeply connected to the
prophetic destiny of westeros
but will this destiny save westeros or
lead to more
fire and tragedy dunk says we never know
what the morrow will bring all he can do
is try his best to be a true knight
the hedge knight asks what does it mean
to be
a true knight it's clearly not about
being a
highborn noble warrior with sword and
armor cause
arion's a piece of [ __ ] and it's not
about being skilled or smart
cause dunk isn't it was dunk's foolish
romantic impulse that led him to be a
hero in the first place
it's not about a special ceremony and
it's not about telling the truth
dunk and egg both lie to get to the
tourney
a big part of what makes dunk a hero is
his
humility noble lords and knights have
too much to lose to want to fight for
justice
but dunk has nothing to lose but his
honor and that's why he risks everything
to protect
others as a low-born commoner he's more
sympathetic to other common people
and dunk's humble origins are what allow
him to beat arion
using dirty flea bottom fighting tricks
to bait the fancy prince
humility helps make dunk a true knight
so at the end of the story micah offers
for dunk and egg to join his
knights at his castle but instead dunk
takes egg on the road to live
as a hedge knight because that humility
will help egg grow
into a better man and a better king
the story criticizes a corrupt system of
nobility
and celebrates a more humble ideal of
heroism where
anyone with courage and strength and
compassion
can be a true knight and 90 years later
brienne's story explores the same ideas
like dunk she's technically not a knight
she's not particularly smart
or special but she's strong and brave
and selfless and determined to do what's
right
which makes her more of a true knight
than almost any actual knight
in book four brienne describes an old
shield from her father's armory which
looks exactly like
dunk's shield with the tree and star so
for years fans have speculated that
brienne
and dunk might be related and at a
convention author george martin
confirmed that dunk
is brienne's ancestor possibly her
great-grandpa
so dunk's legacy as a humble true knight
continues in brienne at the end of the
hedge night
dunk and egg head off for more
adventures there are two more duncan egg
stories after the hedge night
and you can get all of them on audiobook
for free right now by signing up for a
trial with audible
a knight of the seven kingdoms collects
all three duncan egg stories
read on audiobook by harry lloyd the
actor who played viserys on game of
thrones
or you could get june or his dark
materials
audible members get an audio book each
month plus audible originals and if you
cancel you keep the audio books
you can listen while you ride with your
squier or while you sleep beneath the
stars
sign up at audible.com asx
comment below if you want more videos
about the next two dunkin egg stories
thanks to the artists and check out the
articles linked below for more on the
hedge night
thanks for watching and thanks to the
patrons including amanda lim
jack stasco jogging c137 prince
jaehaerys flinted steel
marianne fletcher janine clark and
sneaky penguin
cheers
i offer you a nice egg in this trying
time